Nikki and Brie Bella their sisterly bond
is stronger than ever
especially since they've been twinning
throughout their whole pregnancy let's
see this box ladies I'm gonna get how
are you feeling right now you are in the
homestretch sisters we both are very
tired trying to get as much sleep as we
can for the babies we're really excited
Nikki's new date is just a week and a
half after Brees I will not be shocked
any updates on your birthday plans as of
now only Artem can be in there so our
don't have to film they really want free
in there with me and I'm hoping that we
could bring it total Bella's producers
so Creon are can just be in the moment
with me and not worry about filming brie
and Bryan are waiting to find out if
Bertie is getting a brother or sister
[Music]
but Nikki and Artemis big gender reveal
is happening tonight on the total
Bella's finale I'm excited that
everyone's finally gonna know tonight
[Applause]
when you finally see what color shoots
up in the air it's just it's really fun
but yeah so it's gonna do plates hanging
the name where are you guys on names so
no matter what like Russian tradition
girl or boy you always take the father's
middle name and arms last seems
obviously very Russian so thinking of
names to flow it very difficult like
very good so we we finally hop please
stick to the beads because Brian is
whole family would be everyone our
family's beads boy or girl The Bella
Twins are both committed to educating
their little ones on how to be kind to
other birdie in the shoes three I saw
who stationed with her about having a
kind heart for everyone that we're all
and you treat everyone the same it's my
duty as a parent to instill in her
love and kindness and peace I definitely
agree with free I want to educate my
baby just to have such an open heart and
open mind and stand up for the people
and the communities that needed
[Music]